in bangkoks straßen ist nicht nur der
verkehr chaotisch auch die strom- und
telefonkabel laufen kreuz und quer doch
die stadtverwaltung will die leitungen
nun in den boden verlegen
der hauptvorteil ist dass die sicherheit
des elektrizitätsnetzes verbessert wird
wenn die kabel im untergrund verlaufen
werden störungen beseitigt die zu
stromausfällen führen können mehr als
1000 strommasten wurden bereits entfernt
der plan ist in den kommenden fünf
jahren 39 straßen zu entwirren
damit soll bangkok auch schöner gemacht
werden bangkok ist bekannt für seine
ganzen kabel
es ist ein bisschen wie spaghetti oder
aufgeräumt
thailands militärregierung hat schon
seit einiger zeit pläne für mehr ordnung
in der hauptstadt erst wurden viele der
bekannten streetfood stände geschlossen
nun sollen auch die kabel vorhänge
verschwinden